this program is brought to you by Emory
University
sugar is under a lot of different names
on food and some of the common ones
would be sucrose sugar cane sugar high
fructose corn syrup corn syrup corn
sugar as a newer one that's being used
there's not anything particularly bad
about all these sugars that are added
it's that we're getting too much of it
so it's really that it's in more foods
than we expected or then we can handle
and were individually people are
choosing to drink or eat too much of
things to have sugar in them sugar is
probably just fine for our bodies in
small amounts which is why the
recommendations are not that we get zero
sugar there's nothing evil about sugar
but getting too much sugar is hard on
our bodies and it contributes to you
know increased cardiovascular risk
possibly weight gain and a lot of things
that we wouldn't want so it's more the
volume that we get than anything
particularly special about sugar one of
the things that parents do ask me a lot
is is well then okay if I shouldn't give
them the sweet drink what should I give
them and i recommend water and milk so
about three glasses of milk per day is
typical for a child who likes milk and
can handle milk and then water really is
the best drink the rest of the time kids
probably don't get enough not enough
water in our society and so I think
learning to drink plain water is
probably a good lifelong habit and
really something that a parent can give
their child to really increase their
their health that said you know I think
the transition if a child is used to
very sweetened drinks that transition
can be difficult and so there are so
some tips some ways to do that might be
to gradually decrease the amount of
sweetness and drink so start watering
things down use water for most of the
day but then have a special like this
neck
can have a small you know small amount
appropriate like four to six ounces of
something sweet
you
the preceding program is
by Emory University